So
um we've done the Greeks and we've done
the Israelites and today we discuss the
Persians and today I introduce to you
the most influential
person who who has ever lived and his
name is Zorathustra.
Okay. And Zorustra
will create the world's first
uh great religion world religion called
Zorashinism. And this will lead to the
rise of the world's first great empire
called the Persian Aid Empire. Okay. So
to understand uh Zorusta, let's go back
and understand how we humans have
traditionally understood the world.
Okay. So intuitively we've understood
that the world is one of consciousness.
Okay. The universe is conscious. It's
constantly vibrating. Okay. These
vibrations are infinite.
And the lower that the vibrations go,
the slower they are and therefore they
give rise to matter. Okay? And that
gives rise to uh humans. So we both
inhabit the material universe but our
minds inhabit the spiritual universe.
And um as a result when we vibrate as
well our consciousness returns to to the
universe. Okay. So we're in constant
dialogue with the universe. Now this is
hard to understand. So we've used
metaphors or stories to explain this uh
system. All right. So let's go over how
uh we've we've explained the system
using metaphors. So this is God. Okay.
The god is called the monad or the one
or noose. But there are different names
for this God. And this God is perfect.
The problem with perfection is that you
lack imagination. You lack creativity.
And that's why when God emanates, he
created us. Okay? Humans. Why? Because
we are material. We have bodies and
therefore we are imperfect. What this
means is that when we hit a wall, we
feel pain. We can fall down. We can die.
Um we can suffer. We can make mistakes.
At the same time, it is through
constantly making mistakes,
disobedience, fallibility that we are
able to be creative. Okay?
And as a result both God and we are in
the process of becoming okay we are
becoming into perfection we are be we
are becoming into eternity and infinity
and so we are co-creators with God.
[snorts] Now there are certain
characteristics about the system
um that you have to remember. Okay,
first of all in the system we need to
have free will
because
only by having complete freedom can we
be truly creative. The monatic is
controlling us then um there can't be
any creativity. It's it's all
intentional. It's all planned. Okay. So
free will is very important. Another
very very important idea is the
individual.
Okay. So what so how the system works is
what matters is what happens inside of
us. Okay? Because only us individually
can give rise to creativity.
And so it is our interactions with the
monad that's important. Okay. Another
way of saying this is that
use a metaphor. Okay. The metaphor is a
candle.
A candle. Sorry, this is a bad drawing.
Okay. Candle. And we are all mirrors
surrounding this candle and we are all
candle is reflected in us. Okay. So the
monad is in us and um we are all part of
together. So what happens is what
happens to us individually. Okay.
[snorts]
Another very important part of this is
it's eternity. Okay. Reincarnation.
The idea here is that when you die, you
just don't disappear. Your consciousness
returns to the spirit world. Why?
Because maybe in this world, you made a
lot of mistakes. And because you made a
lot of mistakes, you can't really
appreciate all the pain you've caused.
So when you return to spirit world, then
it's a time for you to reflect and
understand your significance on this
world. Okay? And so the idea is that if
you done a lot of good in this world, if
you've been virtuous, you ascend to a
higher plane. And if you did a lot of
bad things, then you stay in the lower
realm. Okay? And this idea of heaven and
hell. Why? Because if you did a lot of
good, first of all, you can appreciate
all that all that you've done. You can
be closer to the moon at okay. If you've
done a lot of bad, then you will see for
yourself all that that the hurt you've
caused in the world.
Okay. And you be you'll be further down
from the monad. So this is how
intuitively we've understood the
universe to work. Okay. When we're born,
we're b we're born almost with an
intuitive understanding of this. Okay.
The problem is that as our populations
continue to grow and grow, eventually we
have war. Okay. And war gives rise to uh
patriarchy
and property. Why? Because how do you
incentivize people to go fight? Well,
you promise them this wife will be
yours. Okay? You'll be the master of the
household and whatever you win, whether
it's gold or whatever, it will be yours
forever. Okay? And so these three
things, war, patriarchy, and property
are all interlin together. Okay? And
this you can argue gives rise to the
idea of capital. [snorts] Remember when
we last discussed the bronze age, the
bronze age was the height of capital and
therefore it was the height of war,
slavery, corruption,
okay, violence, evil in this world. And
in this time there will emerge prophets,
the port prophets who come and tell us
that what we're doing is wrong. And we
must remember who we came from
originally. Okay? We must remember that
we are part of the monad and that we're
here to celebrate life, not to destroy
life, to be creative, not to be
destructive, to love, not to make war.
Okay? And so um during the bronze age
emerges a man named Zorathustra
and
he is a port prophet just like Homer and
the Yahweh is um and he's dealing with a
situation. Okay, we've enter a system
where war, patriarch and property are
prevalent and we can't imagine a world
without these things. So now he has to
create a new system. He has he has to
present for his poetry new ideas that
help us return to the monad. Okay. And
so he creates the beginnings of a new
world religion called uh zurashinism.
Okay. So let's go over the basic ideas.
So remember that this is a polytheistic
world where you fight for your god. And
the gods don't really care about what's
good and what's evil. All they care
about is themselves. So you celebrate
them. you make sacrifices to them. If
you give them enough money, if you
bought them well enough, then you win
wars. Okay? So that's a system that is
that we call polytheism.
So what um Azora Master does is that he
reimagines system and creates a new
hierarchy where a haram master
is
the top god. Okay? And you can call him
a monad as well. And for for Zor Zor
Thusra, Aurora Master is the lord of
wisdom. Okay, it literally translate
into lord of wisdom and he's represented
by the idea of fire. Okay. So what is
astronism in Chinese? It's
right.
Okay. The religion of white fire. It's a
religion of wisdom.
And what then he also says is that the
war of heaven and hell is within us.
Okay. And there are two forces that tear
at us that divide us. Okay. The first is
a force of asha.
The second is the force of
okay these ideas are hard to translate
but asha just means truth
and douch means the lie.
Okay. So, the Greeks um really admire
the Persians. And what and what they
said about the Persians is the Persians
are good at three things. They're good
at um
horse riding. They're good at archery.
They're good at telling the truth. The
Persians find it abhorrent, hateful to
lie. So, they're always telling the
truth. Okay. Uh but that's a very
simplistic understanding of the system.
Telling the truth is not what Asha is,
right? Um what Asha really is is a
system of virtue.
By being virtuous, by doing good in the
world, you become closer to a master.
You become his representative on earth.
So um to better understand this idea,
all right, I'm going to introduce to you
um another concept called the
categorical imperative.
Okay. So, Emanuel Kant, so we don't know
when Zor Zoro uh Zorathusa lived, okay,
but he lived about 3,000 years ago. Emil
Kant um is the 18th century. Okay, so
he's closer to our time. And he
introduces a concept called the
categorical imperative.
[snorts]
For him, the categorical imperative is
the highest moral law, the highest moral
good, what we all should strive to. And
what I will show you is that it's very
similar to the concept of asha. [snorts]
So there are three
um principles of the category
imperative. The first the most important
is the law of universality.
And what this idea states is that
what is good? Well to know what is good
imagine this. Imagine that whatever you
do, whatever you say, everyone in the
world will immediately do as well. Okay?
So if you get angry, everyone gets angry
at the same time. If you are violent,
everyone everyone's violent at the same
time. Okay? If you curse God, everyone
curses God. Do you want to live in a
world like that? Obviously not. Okay? So
that is what the categorical imperative
is. act and do and think as though
everything you do will be reflected
throughout the universe and you are the
universe itself.
Okay. Now um this idea has been
misunderstood as uh the golden law right
or do onto others as others would do
unto you. But actually no it's it's a
much higher concept. The higher concept
is that imagine that you are God
yourself. Okay? And you everything you
do will be reflected throughout the
universe. Then how would you behave?
Well, you would behave with the highest
virtue. Okay? Because you want to make
the world a better place because if you
do bad things, people are going to do
bad things to you. Okay? So that's the
first idea. It's very important idea.
Second idea
um is free will.
So whatever you do cannot be coerced.
Okay? Whatever you do must be out of
your own desire, your own will, your own
valition, your own choice. Otherwise,
it's wrong. Okay? So I cannot make you
do good. You only want to do good by
yourself. If you want to do evil, you
should do evil because it's your choice.
Okay? Even though it leads to a worse
world, it's important to maintain the
principle of free will and free choice.
Okay. Now, last is the idea of humans
as the end.
Now, you have heard maybe heard the
phrase the means to an end, right? So,
um maybe I'm a king and I need to build
a better world. So, I need to start
wars, conquer the world. So, I need to
sacrifice a billion human beings in
order to create a perfect world. Right?
That may sound good in theory, but what
Kant and Zorustra would say is that's
wrong because humans are the end onto
themselves. Every life, every human life
is as valuable as all human life
together.
Okay? You cannot sacrifice one person
for the sake of the others. That is
fundamentally wrong. Do never do that.
That can only lead you into hell. Okay?
So these three things together gives us
a concept of Asha.
You can see or you can see immediately
how complicated it is. But at the same
time you can also understand how
revolutionary it is. Okay. Because now
Asha presents to us three new concepts
that will revolutionize human history.
They are the individual.
What matters is what matters inside of
you. Okay? Everyone's doing bad. That's
their problem. Don't worry about them.
Just do what is good to you. Okay? What
is good for you. The second is free
choice.
Don't ever feel as though you're being
forced to do something.
Do something because you will it. So,
okay. And then last is truth. Why do you
do this? Because the monad will know.
Okay? Because a horiz master will know.
Because you will know. Okay? So what
your family says, what your community
says, what your nation says does not
matter. Only what you feel in your heart
matters. Okay? And let's introduce a new
concept in human history called
montheism.
And guess what guys?
Zoroism will give birth to three new
religions. Okay? Judaism,
Christianity,
and Islam.
Right? And this together is two to three
point billion people on earth. And
that's why I say Zorra Thusra is the
most important individual who's ever
lived because he will create the
structure for montheism. Okay. These
three concepts that will give rise to
three world religions.
All right. Okay. So something else I
want you to understand is that Zor thus
had a major impact on the Greeks um
especially Greek philosophy. In fact,
the Greeks didn't consider him just a
poet. They considered him the first
scientist, the first uh astronomer, the
first um um philosopher, the first
magician. Okay, the Greek is reverence
for him. Um and Plato will take a lot of
his ideas and create a very powerful
metaphor that helps us understand Asher
better. Okay, it calls it the allegory
of the cave.
>> [snorts]
>> So imagine this. Imagine that we are in
a cave. Okay? We're all prisoners inside
a cave. We are chained to the ground.
Okay? So we can't ever get up. We can't
even move our necks. We only stare at
the wall in front of us. Now behind us
is a fire. And this fire is projecting
shadows onto the wall. Okay? And we give
names to these shadows. And this is what
we call reality.
Okay? But it's a shadow reality. It's
all fake. It's all false. It's all what
we imagine it to be. One day, for
whatever reason, one of us, the chains
disappear. And so we stumble upwards
out of the cave. Okay? And now we're
suddenly in the light, right? We see the
sun. The sun of course is Asha truth.
Okay? or a haram master
and we're blinded because our eyes are
used to seeing the dark, right? We can't
see. We feel nothing but pain for a long
long time. But over time, we start to
see more clearly and we see the world is
beautiful. Okay? We see the birds flying
in the sky. We see the trees around us.
We see the animals and we're like, "This
is beautiful." Okay? I found heaven. I
found the truth. I found Asha. I have
found a haram master. This is what life
is really about. Okay.
But over so but after some time you're
like but this is not enough. Okay. I
have found the truth but the truth is
not complete because I know there are my
friends my family that are stuck inside
the cave. Therefore for me to fully
achieve Asha I must go down and tell
them the truth. Tell them there is an
asha and we can all break through our
chains, escape into the light and see
the truth for ourselves and then we will
be truly happy and free and wise. Okay,
that's what ashra is. Asha is not just
breaking through your chains and seeing
the truth for yourself but it's a
responsibility to go and spread this
virtue to everyone around you. If you
see injustice, speak out. M
>> okay another way of saying this is let's
use a metaphor a choir okay singing
choir
how's a choir work well our master the
monad he's singing a song
we have to sing along with him okay
if we do that the world is harmonized
the world is perfect the world is per is
beautiful but if most of us are out of
tune then we need to get into tune right
>> okay So that's what Asha is. Asha is not
just selfindalization,
self-truth. It is helping others see the
truth for themselves. Okay. So if you
yourself see the truth, you now have
responsibility to teach this truth to
others.
But the problem is of course if you go
down and tell everyone, hey man, this
world we're living in is a shadow world.
>> It's a prison. We need to break our
chains and escape into the real world.
Everyone's like, "You're crazy, man."
[snorts] Right? Get out of here, man.
You're crazy.
And they're like, "No, no, no, no. We
have to go." And they're like, "Okay,
well then describe this world to us."
And you're like, "Um, it's hard. It's
kind of hard to describe."
>> Well, you're crazy then. Okay. All
right. So, that's Plato's allego the
cave. All right. And this gives you a
better understanding of
um the idea of Asha. Okay. So
if you move towards the truth, you're
moving towards Asha. But if you're
moving away from Asha, you're moving
towards the Drew. Okay.
[snorts]
All right. So that's a basic premise of
um Zorashinism. This is the idea that uh
Zorus brought to the world and will
forever change the world. Okay, we'll go
into the specific history next week, but
first what I want to do this week is
just go into his ideas. Okay. All right.
All right.
So, Zorathusa, we don't know when he
lived, okay? But we estimate anywhere
between the year 2000 B.CE to about a
th000 BC. That's a bronze age, right? I
suspect he he lived towards the end of
the bronze age. Why? Because when the
bronze age is coming into the form,
people are in love with capitalism.
People want to get rich, right? But
after the system matures, there's
slavery, there's debt, there's
corruption, there's misery, there's
suffering and so people want to hear
another voice. Zor Thusa himself was a
priest and it was disgusted by the
corruption of priest because remember
being a priest means being a teacher
leading people into the light leading
people into Asha. But once uh the
branches becomes more mature then
priests are corrupt. They uh want a lot
of money for helping you achieve
immortality. Um they sort of spread
false teachings. Okay. become very
corrupt and so uh Zorusta becomes
disgusted and he wanders around
spreading his new message of Asha. Okay.
Now um what's important to understand is
that we don't know where Zorusa worked
specifically but we suspect northern
Iran. Okay. Why is this important?
Because during the branch age um the
main centers of wealth were Mesopotamia,
Egypt, the Levant. So this is more like
a colony where there's a lot of mining
going on. Okay. So what's going on here
is basically the most human suffering in
the world. Okay. So imagine maybe Congo
where they're using they're using um
child slaves to dig for rare earths.
Okay. It's it it's a margin empire where
war is a very common thing. Violence is
very common thing. People are being
kidnapped and forced to work in the
minds in order to get tin for the branch
age economy. Okay.
All right. So as you can see um Zorusa
is about here. Okay. Either northeast
Iran or northwest uh Iran. Okay. And as
and as I mentioned the global economy is
around here. Okay. This is where most
most of the wealth is. These people are
poor. They're enslaved and they're
extremely violent. Okay.
All right. So
Zorusa comes and he's a poet prophet.
Okay. He's a priest and he's singing
songs to help people better understand
the world around them. He's trying to
remind them of who they are really.
Okay, they really are parts of God. All
right, so he says, "Listen with your own
ears, with a bright mind. Choose truth
from false creed. Each person for his
own self before the final judgment
comes." Okay. So the idea of in the
individual, what matters is yourself.
What you do, what your family does, what
your clan does, what your tribe does not
matter. What you do because when you
die, you will face a masta, the final
judgment. Okay? Not your family but you
yourself. And so what you must do is
choose asha the truth. Okay. What is the
truth? Being virtuous because you
yourself are virtue.
Okay. Um
so um he wrote in a language called
Avasten and it's a beautiful language
and if you are a Zoroastrian priest you
can memorize all this okay but I am not
and I don't want to butcher the language
okay but it's poetry it's beautiful
right so ash is the best of all that is
good and ash is happiness happiness
belongs to the one who follows the
righteous path for the sake of the best
righteousness so how do you know you're
doing asha because you are happy. Okay,
do you understand? So the metaphor is
imagine that you live in a world of like
fat people who don't exercise and all
they do is watch TV, right? And but you
decide to go and work out and you become
more fit. How do you know you're on the
right path? Because you feel happier
about yourself. Okay,
but the problem of course is that you
lose all your friends. You lose all your
family. Okay, that's why people don't do
this. Not because um they don't know the
truth. is because they fear the truth.
>> All right. So, so this is some trusted
poetry called agathas that we know that
Jorah thus wrote. Okay. Or he didn't
write it. They were all illiterate at
this point, but he sang it. Okay. Now,
the two primal spirits who reveal
themselves in vision as twins are the
better and the bad in thought and word
and action. And between these two, the
wise ones choose all right. The foolish
one not so. Okay. So we in our nature
always um divide into into two halves.
Okay. The good and the bad. The asha and
the douch. And to be truly virtuous, it
has to be good thoughts,
um good words and good actions. Okay?
You have to be unified as a person. You
can't speak the truth but then do bad
things. Okay? You have to think good
thoughts, speak good thoughts, and do
good works. And that's what um
Zarashinism. Okay?
And when these twain spirits came
together in the beginning, they created
life and not life. And that at the last
worst existence shall be the followers
of the lie, but the best existence to
him that follows right. Of these two
twin spirits, he that followed the life,
the lie choose doing the worst things,
the holiest spirit choose right. He that
clothe him with a massy heavens as a
garment. So likewise, they that are fain
to please aaram master by beautiful
actions.
Between these twin, the Davas, okay,
those that lead you to the Drewge also
chose not a right for infatuation came
upon them as they took counsel together.
So that they chose the worst thought.
Then they rushed together to violence
that they might infeas
by demons who choose violence to control
us. Okay? And and what do you do? And to
him came dominion and good mind and
right and piety gave continued life to
their bodies and indestructibility so
that by they retributions through metal
he may gain the prize over the others.
Even in a world of evil you can choose
and you must choose to be good. All
right? If people are lying you tell the
truth because what matters is your
individual action not what others are
doing.
>> [snorts]
>> So when there cometh their punishment
for their sins, then oh master at thy
command shall good thought establish the
dominion in a consump consummation for
those who deliver the lie or harara into
the hands of right. Okay. So God will
know what what good you did, what evil
you did. Okay. When you die, it'll be
the final judgment. You will have to
face God. So we may be those that make
this world advance. Oh master Master and
you order come hither thou shaving a
mission into your company and Asha in
order that our thought may gather
together while reason is still shaky.
Okay so even though the world has turned
evil even though the people the elite
are evil you can still do good and God
will know you do good and God will
reward you for doing good. Okay. So
again, this is the beginning of
monotheism. And as you can see, this
idea will echo in Christianity and Islam
as well.
Then truly on the world of lie shall
come the destruction of the light. But
they who get themselves good name shall
be partakers in the promised reward in
the fair abol of good thought of master
and of right. Oh, if, oh ye mortals, ye
mark those commandments which master
have ordained of happiness and pain, the
long punishment for the follower of the
drew, and blessings for the followers of
the right, then hereafter shall it be
well. Okay? So you should do what is
virtuous, not only because God uh will
reward you for doing so, but because you
will feel eternal happiness in doing so.
When though amass in the beginning did
create the individual and individuality
through thy spirit and powers of
understanding when though did make life
clothed with a body when actions and
teachings whereby one may exercise one's
convictions at once free. Okay. So you
see individual free will these are the
core concepts here. Okay. Never say
you're being coerced. You always have
the choice. You always have the choice
to resist.
Then lifts up his voice the false
speaker or the true speaker. He that
knows or he that knows not each
according to his own heart and mind
passing from one to another. Ar matei
confers with a spirit in whom there is
wavering. Okay.
Clear it is to the man of understanding
as one who has realized it with thought.
He upholds Asha together with good
dominion by his word and deed. He will
be oh master the most helpful helper to
thee. Okay. So when we choose to follow
Asha, we are doing God's work. When we
in our hearts choose Asha, we at the at
that moment change the world for the
better. Okay.
All right. So this sounds a bit
complicated, a bit abstract and honestly
he was speaking to people at that time.
Okay. So what does he really really mean
and how can we understand what he's
really saying? Well, the argument I want
I I I want to make you today is that all
part prophets are the same. They're all
divinely inspired. They're all speaking
a certain truth. So by understanding
other part prophets of that region of
that culture, we gain insight into the
true thinking of Zoro. Okay. So this is
Roomie who is considered the greatest
Persian poet who has ever lived. He
lived in the 13th century which is about
2,000 years 3,000 years after
Zorathustra. In many ways if you
actually read his poetry he is the
reincarnation
of Zorathustra. Okay. So we're going to
read a bit of his poetry and then once
you read his poetry they'll give you
insight into the cosmology of
Zorashinism.
All right. I see so deeply with myself.
I so see deeply with myself not needing
my eyes. I can see everything clearly.
Why would I want to bother my eyes again
now that I see the world through his
eyes? His eyes. Okay. Through the eyes
of Asha, through the eyes of the Monad,
through our master. Okay. That's what
how you should be seeing. Okay? In other
words, you should be seeing the world
through your imagination.
You can imagine a better world. If you
imagine a better world, you can create a
better world. So don't be fooled by the
material world around us. It's all fake.
It's all an illusion.
Not Christian or Jew or Muslim. Not
Hindu, Buddhist, Sufi or Zen. Not any
religion or cultural system. I'm not
from the east or the west. Not out of
the ocean or up from the ground. Not
natural or ether. Not compulsive
elements at all. I do not exist. I'm not
an an entity in this world or in the
next. Do not descend from Adam and Eve
or any origin story. My place is
placeless. A trace of the traceless.
Neither body or soul. I belong to the
beloved. have seen the two worlds as one
and that one called and no first last
outer inner only that breath breathing
human being. Okay, does that make sense
to you? We're all part of God.
That's our true nature. There's a divine
spark in us. Don't be fooled by the
material world. Okay? And don't be
fooled by labels.
Christians,
Buddhists,
Jews, there's no difference. We're all
the God children of God, okay? We're all
the same. So don't be fooled by labels.
Okay? So there's a joke. Okay? The joke
is this. God and Satan are fighting over
humanity. And God says to Satan, "Ha,
humans have discovered religion.
Therefore, I have won." And then Satan
says, "Yeah, but then I'll just organize
it." Okay. So the idea is that religion
is great. Okay? Okay, I'm a big
supporter of religion, but organized
religion is problematic because
organized religion serves the interests
of the priests who control the religion.
Okay? And that's why there are the
differences in these religions in
Buddhism, in Judaism, and Islam and
Christianity because the people in
charge need to differentiate the
religion in order to um exploit you,
okay? In order to justify their
existence. But at the end of the day,
we're all connected to the vine and all
that matters is our connection. Okay? So
all these uh differences is something
that is artificially created to fool us.
All right. All that I think about it
then I say it where did I come from and
what am I supposed to be doing? Okay. I
have no idea. My soul is from elsewhere.
I'm sure of that and I intend to end up
there. Okay. I don't remember where I
came from but I know that I must have
come from somewhere. Okay.
This began in some other realm, some
other tavern. When I get back around to
that place, I'll be completely sober.
Meanwhile, I'm like a bird from another
continent, sitting in his Avery. The day
is coming when I fly off. But who is it
now in my ear who hears my voice? Who
says word words within my mouth? Who
looks out with my eyes? What is a soul I
cannot stop asking? If I could taste one
of for an answer, I could break out of
this prison for drunks. I didn't come
here on my own accord. I can't leave
that way. Whoever brought me here will
have to take me home. Okay, this is
beautiful. And it's also a rewriting of
the Plato of Plato's allegory of the
cave. Right? This is a prison for
drunks. Here we're all drunk. We're all
blind from our true reality. This is
just a prison. When we return to the
Monad to Master, then we'll see the
truth for ourselves. Okay.
All right. So, here's another poor
prophet, Federick Nichi. Okay. Fred
Nichi is one of the three great German
philosophers of the past um 500 years.
Um Emanuel Kant, Frederick Hegel and
Ferdick Nishi and Ferdick Nichi wrote
does spoke Zorah and he wrote in a very
interesting way. He likes to take these
long walks. He can walk walk for like
hours and hours in the mountains and
then now and then he feels as though
he's being seized. Okay, a force has
seized him and compels him to speak and
he believes this person is Zoro.
Okay. So he wrote a book and it just is
a recollection of all the moments when
he was seized by Zorusta and forced to
speak his words. All right. And we
actually read what Nichi writes, you
will see that it's actually pretty
similar to what Zorusa himself
um promoted during his time. Of course,
Nichi is uh promoting it in a more
modern contemporary lens. Okay. So, if
Zoroa were to come back, uh he would be
he'll basically be Nichi. Okay. So, in
many in many ways, Nichi and Roomi are
reincarnations of Zorustra. They're all
trying to speak a divine truth to
humanity.
All right. So, this is the prologue, the
first page of the spec zorra. Okay. And
what you will notice, okay, look for
this. What you will notice is that this
exactly like the atta
was 30 years old, he left his home in
the lake of his home and went into the
mountains. There he enjoyed his spirit
in a solitude and for 10 years did not
wear of it. But at last his heart
changed, and rising one morning of the
rosy dawn, he went before the sun and
inspect thus onto it. Though great star,
what would thy happiness if thou had not
those for whom thou shineest? For 10
years hast thou climbed hither unto my
cave, though would have weather of thy
light and of the journey, had it not
been for me mine eagle and my serpent.
But we awaited thee every morning, took
from thee thine overflow, and bless thee
for it. Lo, I'mware of my wisdom, like
the bee that hath gathered too much
honey. I need hands outstretched to take
it. I would fain bestow and distribute
until the wise have once more become
joyous in the folly and the poor happy
in their riches. Therefore my I I
descend into the deep as though does in
the evening when though go behind the
sea and give light also to the neither
world though exuberant star like thee
must I go down as men say to whom I
shall descend. Okay so Zorusta has hid
himself in a cave and in inside the cave
in solitude he has discovered Asha. He
has discovered the secrets of the
universe. And he's discovered that this
is not enough. I must now go shine the
light on everyone. Otherwise, I can
never achieve a fully. Okay? So, it's
exactly like the other girl in the cave
where the prisoner, he escapes into the
light and he's happy until he realizes
that you can't be happy alone. You have
to share this happiness with everyone
else. Okay? So, it's exactly like the
algorith.
[snorts] All right, let's continue.
Though in Plantus thy highest aim to the
heart of those passions, then became thy
virtues and joys. And though were of the
race of the hot-tempered or the
volutuous or the fanatical or the
vindictive, all thy passions in the end
become virtues, and all thy devils
angels. Once had those while dogs in thy
cellar, but they change at last into
birds and charming songstresses. Out of
thy poisons breed though balsom for them
for thyself. Thy cow affliction milk so
th though drinkkeeth though the sweet
milk of her other. And nothing evil grow
in thee any longer unless it be the evil
that grow out of the conflict of thy
virtues. My brother, if thou be
fortunate, then will thou have one
virtue and no more. Thus goes no easier
over the bridge. Illustrious is to have
many virtues but a hard lodge. And many
of one have gone into the wilderness and
killed himself because he wasware of
being the battle and battlefield of
virtues. Okay. Question then is
if our master is wisdom why do we live
in a world of hate of evil of sin and
the answer is because virtue must come
from vice good can only come from evil
okay to live in good forever is to live
in ignorance okay we are born in the
drew so that we we may discover Asha
from our struggles we will discover what
truly good is and that's a gift that God
has given us to grow to live in a time
of evil so that we may ourselves may
create good for humanity. Okay, that's
the central message of of this without
vice there can be no virtue and to have
one virtue itself is not enough. You
must be constantly in a battle to create
more and more virtue. Okay. So if you
are a man of sin or a woman of evil,
be thankful because now is your
opportunity to be a star, a a son that
through transformation of oneself can
can brighten the world. Okay? And when
you do that, you transform the world.
And then when you after you do that,
your next battle is to go and transform
someone else or to look deeper and
discover the evil in you. Okay? So don't
worry about the world itself. Just worry
about you yourself because within
yourself is a universe of evil that can
be transformed into a universe of good.
So um one really important thing I I I
have to say is that this is not
Buddhism. Okay. The the structure and
the framework are very similar. But what
Zoro Zor ainism fundamentally says is
that
compassion
is not enough. Okay. You have to act
because justice is about action. If you
see injustice, you must speak out. You
can't be like, "Oh, um inde I'm
indifferent because I'm compassionate."
Okay, that's not enough. You have to act
out. And that's why uh people who
believed in this religion were so
creative, okay? Because they believe in
action. Being indifferent is simply
being
is basically being complicit in the
system, right?
All right. Ye tell me life is hard to
bear, but for what purpose shall you
have your pride in the morning and your
resignation in the evening? Life is hard
to bear, but not affect to be so
delicate. We are all of us find some
asses and she assasses. Okay. What we
have in common with a rose bud which
trembleth because a drop of dew have
formed upon it. It is true that we love
life not because we are want to live but
because we are want to love. Love is
Asha, right? Um we want always want to
achieve asha. There's always some
madness in love, but there's always also
some method in madness. And to me also
who appreciate life, the butterflies and
soap bubbles and whatever is like them
amongst us seem most to enjoy happiness.
To see those light, foolish, pretty,
liely little sprites flit about that
move Zasa through tears and songs. I
should only believe in a god that would
know how to dance. [snorts] And when I
saw my devil, I found him serious,
thorough, profound, and solemn. He was a
spirit of gravity. Through him, all
things fell. Okay. So, what Nishi hates
is organized religion because organized
religion it is very serious, very
somber. He basically wants to enslave
us, right? It's like don't do anything
bad. Don't drink, don't smoke, don't
have sex or you'll burn in hell. Okay,
that's very serious. And what Zurusta
and what Nisha is saying is that that's
not what Asha is, man. Ashes recognized
that the world is beautiful, that our
master is all merciful, all forgiving,
all love, all compassion and you must
delight in the world because that's why
he created us. Okay? So the only way to
survive this world of evil is to
recognize that beauty is everywhere
around us and there's our responsibility
to discover this beauty and celebrate
this beauty. Okay? Dance, sing, make
love, laugh, smile. That's what life is
about. Okay? If a priest is telling you,
hey, uh, meditate for your life because
only through that will you avoid sin.
He's a devil, man. Okay? Because he's
denying you your free will. He's denying
you your capacity to love, to seek
action yourself.
Okay?
[snorts]
But one day will the solitude worry
thee. One day will thy pride yield and
thy courage quail. Though one day cry,
I'm alone. One day will thou see no
longer thy loftiness and see too closely
thy loneliness. Thus eliminate itself or
frighten thee as a phantom. Thou will
one day cry all false. So life is a
constant struggle, okay, between hope
and tragedy. Um there are some days when
you will be very hopeful, but there are
some days when you'll be very depressed.
That's just the process of life and
that's the process of wisdom. Okay? To
seek wisdom, you always have to
constantly destroy yourself. You have to
destroy the world around you and and
it's a never- ending process of pain and
suffering and tragedy. But it will
gradually lead you to enlightenment.
What's really important is to act okay
to seek self-destruction. So another way
of saying this is
always assume
that
whatever you know no matter how truthful
is probably wrong and to go and negate
yourself. Okay.
It also means leaving your family
leaving your comfort zone.
All right. A heretic will thou be to
thyself. Okay. A heretic is someone who
doubts yourself. Right? Saying
everything I've known is wrong. Okay.
So, another way of saying this and I I
know it's hard to understand is you come
to my class for a semester and
everything I teach you, you're like,
"Wow, this makes a lot of sense." Okay?
And every day you're excited. You learn
a lot. But at the end of semester, what
you want to say is everything I've
learned this semester is wrong. So, I'm
going to learn for myself. I'm going to
get I'm I'm going to negate everything
I've learned and believe everything I've
learned is deceitful so that I can
rebuild my own knowledge. And through
that process will you actually achieve
enlightenment. Okay. The truth is it has
to be to you. There can be no truth for
everyone. The truth has to be for you
and you must fight for it every day.
Okay.
Ready must thou be to burn thyself in
thy own flame. Okay? You must destroy
yourself. How could thou become new if
thou have not first become ashes? Do you
understand? To live is to die. If you
really want to understand, you must
first destroy every everything that that
you think you understand in order to
build a new understanding. Though
lonesome one, though go the way of the
creating one. A god will thou create for
thyself out of the seven de devils.
Though lonesome one, though goes the way
of the loving one. Though loves thyself,
and on account despise thyself as only
the loving one despise. To create desire
the loving one become because he
despised. What know he of love who have
not been obliged to despise just what he
loved. Okay, this is a really hard con
to understand but like you know in the
Buddhist tradition it's like avoid
anger.
No, no, no. Embrace your anger. Embrace
your hate because hate and love go
together. Anger and calm go together.
Okay. So by going to one extreme, you
can now embrace the other extreme and
your life is a constant struggle between
these two different extremes. When you
negate yourself, when you move into
nothingness, you can only move into
ignorance and slavery.
>> Okay? Does that make sense? You are born
of two natures. You must let these two
natures fight. Okay?
[snorts]
All right. When Zorusa had spoken these
words, he paused like one who had not
said his last word, and long balance the
staff undouily in his hand. At least he
spoke thus, and his voice had changed. I
now go alone, my my disciples. Ye also
now go away, and alone so will I have
it. Verily, I advise you, depart from
me, and guard yourselves against
Zorustra, and better still be ashamed of
him. Perhaps he have deceived you. The
man of knowledge must be able not only
to love his enemies, but also hate his
friends. Okay, you want true knowledge,
you can learn from me, but at the end we
must leave each other and you must say
he's now my enemy. I must now destroy
him. If I really want to be myself, I
need to destroy my teachers in order to
discover my true self.
Okay?
And as you can imagine, most people
don't want to do this. Most people just
want to cling to their mother, want to
cling to the teacher. But you can never
achieve true asha if you do this. Okay.
Ye love your virtue as a mother love her
child. But when did one hear of a mother
want to be paid for her love? It is your
dearest self your virtue. The ring's
thirst is in you to reach itself again.
Struggle every ring and turn itself. And
like the star that go out, so is every
work of your virtue. ever is is its
light on its way and traveling? And when
will it cease to be on its way? Thus is
the light of your virtue still on its
way even when its work is done. Be
forgotten and dead still its ray of
light live and travel. Okay, so when we
die, our bodies decompose. What's still
left is our virtue. Okay, that's who we
are. Our virtue, all that good we've
done in the world, all the knowledge,
all the enlightenment, all the emotions
that we've generated, okay, that will be
eternal. And so we must embrace this
nature and become virtue itself. Okay?
Being human is to be first and foremost
virtuous to seek Asha.
For this is the truth. I've departed
from the house of the scholars and the
door have I also slammed behind me. Too
long did my soul sit hungry at their
table. Not like them have I got the
knack of investigating as a knack of
nutcracking. Freedom do I love in the
air over fresh soil. Rather would I
sleep on oxkins than on their honors
indignities. I am too hot and scorched
with thine own thought. Often is it
ready to take away my breath. Then have
I go then I then I have I to go into the
open air and away from all dusty rooms.
But they sit cool in the cool shade.
They want everything to be merely
spectators. And they avoid sitting where
the sun burn on the steps. Like those
who stand in the street and gape at the
passers by. Thus do they also wait and
gape at the thoughts which others have
thought. Okay. So this is a radical idea
but it's very true. You go to university
not to learn how to think but to fall
into ignorance. Okay. Why? Because the
professors
there the priests there they have
departed from reality and they've chosen
to live a life of comfort of ease of
pleasure. And as a result they can't
know anything. True knowledge is can
only be found in the everyday in the
mundane with ordinary people. That's
where God is. Okay. Universe are
constructed to be away from God. They
are temples
for the comfort of priest. So if you
want true knowledge, go out into the
world and talk to another people.
Suffer. Okay.
All right. So that's it. Okay. So now
you you can understand the beauty and
power of Zorusta
and and I I really do believe this. I
really believe that Nishi was channeling
Zorusta, but he was channeling in a way
for the common mind. Okay? Because the
thing about Asha is that it's always
changing. All right? The Asha that was
true 3,000 years ago is not the Asha
that's true for us today. All right? And
what's really important to understand is
that Asha is constantly coming. So you
have to constantly work towards it.
There's no there's no end point to Asha.
>> All right? And Asha is going to be
different for everyone. But if
everyone's moving towards Asha, then the
world becomes a more virtuous, a better
place, and a more just place. Okay? So
um any questions guys?
All right. So um last class I gave a
lecture on um the Bible and I made a
mistake in my lecture. So um in my my
discussion about the story of the
patriarchs um between the love story of
Rachel and Jacob, I said that uh Jacob
had had to work seven years for Rachel
after his marriage to uh Leah. But as uh
this substscriber
um Cole tells me, actually that's not
what the Bible says. The Bible says that
um Laban, the father, gave Rachel to
Jacob right away, but then he had to
work seven years to pay off that debt.
Okay. So, uh thank you to Cole for
correcting the error. In fact, I
probably made a lot of small errors um
in my uh talk last class and and I
obviously made make a lot of mistakes
every class. Okay? So, I apologize for
that. But the thing about this class and
it's really important for us to remember
is that this is a class not about
answers. It's about questions. Okay. So
what makes this class interesting and
special is that we're always asking the
hard questions. What does it mean to be
human? Where do we come from? Why are we
here? Where are we going? Okay. We're
always asking these questions because
these are questions that actually matter
for us. Okay, that's the first thing.
Second thing is that I'm constantly in
the process of becoming. I'm constantly
um trying to discover the answers and so
for for me this is a journey. So for
example um Zorustra is a revelation to
me before I didn't know about Zorusra
and I made a lot of mistakes. So for
example I said that Christianity was the
first monistic religion last um semester
and now I recognize that's wrong. It's
actually zorashinism. Okay. So I'm
constantly in the process of discovery
of becoming
um and what's really important is that
we continue to speculate. We continue to
explore together. All right? And if so
if you don't like what I say this class
or you don't like my opinion, just wait
a year or two and I'll probably change
my opinion. Okay? Because that that's
what true knowledge is about. If you
really want to pursue knowledge, you
must be willing to as Nichi as Zorusa
says, you constantly need to destroy
yourself to burn yourself into ashes so
that you may build yourself a new. Okay?
And that's what the process of um real
education should be about. Okay? So in
this class, I'm not here to give you a
easy answers. I'm not I'm not here to
give you facts that you must memorize.
I'm here to ask you questions that help
you better understand yourself and
better understand the world around you
to help. This class is about
conversation, dialogue, and debate.
>> Okay.
All right. So, any questions, guys?
Yeah. Sorry, give you the mic.
>> Um, so as to say, uh, ash is different
for for different individuals. Um, so I
was thinking about an example is, um, so
Hitler as a racist. Um he he he
not only himself but he also making uh
um some like a lot a lot a lot of people
to hate jewels and let's assume that he
um think jewels are evil in his heart
and trying to destroy them. So if he
think that this is uh real justice, does
this still count for Ash?
>> Okay, look um look, it's a very
sensitive topic, you know, Hitler and
the Holocaust. I don't want to spend too
much time on, okay? But if you truly
understand Asha
um if you truly understand Zoroa what it
would say is that Ara Masta is complete
forgiveness, compassion and love. Okay.
So whatever we do on this in this world
will be forgiven in the end. I I I know
I I I understand this is hard for a lot
of people to accept. Um, I I know that
we grew up knowing that there must be
evil in this world because of the
Holocaust and there must be Satan and
all that, but um, if you really want to
discover Asha, you have to let go of
these ideas and understand that [snorts]
in the end all will be forgiven. Okay,
I'm sure that there are people you hate
in this world and you think that they're
they must burn in hell because of all
the evil they they've done they've done
in this world. But
if we want to appreciate Asha, if we
really want to discover the the truth,
okay, we need to let go of this hatred.
We need to let go of
um of of this judgment. Okay. Um I mean
I mean the the very point of Asha is
don't worry about other people. Just
worry about yourself.
Don't compare yourself to other people.
Compare yourself to yourself. Okay. And
and so how do you know you're moving
towards Asha because you can feel it.
All right. The problem is what keeps us
from Asha are two things. Our ego and
our fear. We want to be liked by
everyone. Our ego. Okay. Our fear of
rejection. people of saying something
that offends other people being
politically correct. Okay? Like I know
that in my class I offend a lot of
people and I get shot at all the time on
YouTube and I know that. Okay. But if I
want to achieve asha I need to take this
risk.
>> Okay? Because at the end of the day what
matters is my own individual pursuit of
the truth. What others think of me does
not matter. Okay? So the problem our
society is we're brainwashed into
thinking that the opinions of others
matter. Okay? What what what your
teacher says about you matters because
the teachation will decide whether or
not you get into good university. How
much money you make matters because that
will give you status in society. Okay?
And what Zoro thusta, what Nichi, what
room, what Plato, they're all saying is
this. It doesn't matter man. What
matters if you want true happiness, if
you want true enlightenment, if you want
uh asha, you have to embark on a
personal journey that requires solitude
that requires rejecting everything that
you know in the past so that you can
rebuild yourself. Once you make that
once you make that that decision action
will come to you naturally. Okay. But
first and foremost, what you need to do
is let go of these prejudices. Let go of
these ideas that have been put into you.
Okay, I know. Yes, I I know I will get
shouted out. I I I I know get cursed
online for saying, you know, Hitler will
be forgiven, but Hitler will be forgiven
because everyone will be forgiven. Okay.
Everyone will be forgiven.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. There is no [snorts]
there is no hell. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
to say this. Okay. I'm sorry to say, but
there is no hell. Hell is what we create
in our hearts.
>> Okay. Everyone will be forgiven.
All right. But but thank you for the
question. Any any more questions?
Okay.
>> Uh my question would be um I know that
Asha for everyone will have different
but like will it change in a different
period like when I was being as a child
or when I grow up would that change?
Um okay so like I I'm not a Zorashian
priest and I I don't want to insult the
religion okay because what they will
tell you is that um at the end of the
day Asher is virtue and God is virtue
okay so so when you do asha you're
moving towards God which is perfection
okay but um I think that what Nichi
would say and maybe thus but I think
Nichi would definitely say this is that
God is creativity okay So God, so what
you really want to do is when you move
towards Asha is to constantly reinvent
yourself to discover new ideas about
yourself. And this is a never- ending
process.
>> Okay? There's no finale finale to it. If
there's no there's no finale to it, that
means that each of us uh will live our
own individual lives that's different
from from others. Okay? And and so what
this means is that Asha will become
different for each of us. But what's
important is and Roomie would say this,
Evan would say this is follow your
heart. Okay? Ignore what others think
dissipate your fears. Okay? Kill your
fears and just believe in yourself.
Follow your heart and action will come
naturally to you. Okay? And when that
happens also, God will come naturally to
you and you'll discover new truths, uh
new powers, new understandings that will
bring you greater happiness in life.
Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Great. Any more questions, guys?
All right.
>> Mean that we'll never
>> Yeah.
>> So, does that mean we'll never be like
like uh not physically, but like with
Asha, but like we're always trying to
get closer with them.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So, again, there's no end point.
Okay. There's no destination here. Okay.
It's becoming. Okay. It's a pos constant
process of becoming. And it's not
possible to seek Asha in one lifetime,
right? That's why we are reincarnated
because we come back and we do it over
again and we move closer towards Asha
each time. But there can never be an end
point. Okay? Because let's just say you
reach that end point. Guess what?
Everyone else hasn't. So you have a duty
now to help other people.
>> Okay?
>> Does that make sense? So if you move
closer to Asha, you also want to move
others closer to Asha. So it's a
constant, it's a constant struggle, but
that's what gives meaning and purpose to
the universe. The fact that we're all
striving to be better. Okay? Virtue,
truth, asha, these are all we strive
for. Okay? There can be no perfection.
There can just be only a process of
becoming.
>> Right? Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So look, I mean, I know people
want simple answers. I know that oh
there'll be there'll be a final judgment
we're going to go to heaven and we'll
live every happy happ happy happ happy
happ happy happ happy happ happy happ
happy happ happy happ happy happ happy
happ happy happily ever after okay
that's not what that's not what the
truth is the truth is that the universe
is a constant process of becoming of
struggle of pain of tragedy but from
that we can build hope and virtue and
good okay all right so thank you so I've
done I've gone over into the three major
civilizations Okay, the Greeks, uh, the
Israelites and the Persians that that
have come after the collapse of the
Bronze Age. Okay, what what I'm going to
do next week is I'm going to put I'm
going to show you how these three
civilizations interact with each other.
Okay, we're going to go into the history
of these civilizations. Okay. All right.
So, I'll see you guys next